ciao ragazzi seguite i miei amici sui
social avrete sicuramente visto che
qualche giorno fa vi abbiamo chiesto una
cosa ossia di farci sapere quali sono
quelle esperienze che non avete mai
fatto ma che avreste sempre voluto
provare qualche giorno infatti stiamo
collaborando con coca cola che ha
lanciato il nuovo prodotto che si chiama
coca cola zero calorie anche con
estratto di stevia è il motto di questo
prodotto è sete di novità e allora per
questo motivo abbiamo deciso di metterci
in gioco e di provare alcune esperienze
nuove
ma non le nostre le vostre debora ci
scrive il sogno che condivido con la mia
migliore amica mariana correre una verso
l'altra fino a scontrarci con i palloni
rimbalzanti tenuti sulla pancia io sono
mamma di famiglia non aveva fatto devi
stare tranquilla spook li 86 dice girare
in pigiama e pantofole allora devo dirti
una cosa il pigiama va beh un pigiama di
gemma però preferisco uno spezzato
no no io sono per l'intero credo che
indosserò un qualcosa che mi faccia
sentire comunque sexy e 100 i comunque
le mie curve mediterranee e magari anche
con una scarpa interessante almeno siamo
già pronti per la sera ci hanno guardato
con in video comunque secondo me per il
tuo modello esclusivo
secondo me una bella accoppiata questo
viola con questo rosso e l'aia famoso
effetto su tono su tono su tono su tono
sul topo io ho avuto questa bella idea
di mettermi in esterni ciabattine che
sono 27 i numeri più piccoli perché
ovviamente per via dei piccoli assaggi
allora don are the unders corre expat
life scrive sedermi sulle ginocchia di
qualcuno quando l'autobus è pieno no io
mi tiro fuori alice disposto a fare
qualsiasi altra cosa dopo
vabbè allora sì il prossimo
chiara scrive attaccare bottone con uno
sconosciuto e offrirgli da bere non
avere rivali non puoi evitare tutto il
genere umano ne faccio un'altra ancora
quella che non ti va di fare io sono
fidanzata non posso andare ad attaccare
bottone con gli sconosciuti al bar
ciao ti di specie se mi siedo chi dà
molto fastidio che
visto che arrivi il cappello capello
anch'io detto pagare in siamo come ci
piace ai capelli ci piace i capelli che
abbiamo in comune
beh ci piacciono i cappelli che vediamo
in questo bar
io mi chiamo liceo ecco piacere di
offrire da bere
ecco qua scusa possa avere dei bicchieri
con del ghiaccio per favore
facciamo un cin cin beh allora alle cose
in comune
aperture dico subito insulti danzata e
anzi c'è o anche dei figli proprio una
grande famiglia
partirò la 90 dice urlare in una
biblioteca
come si chiama tanti ora almeno so chi
odiare
o no
ah ah allora alice ci scrive a me
piacerebbe fare il volo dell'angelo che
fa baby vitucci dancing si può fare
certo però per farlo bisogna un attimo
di costruire il pathos della scena
quindi alla frase a effetto di lui
nessuno mettere in un angolo
l'analisi ortopedica nella schiena di
lei controllo ascella sì
è presa ok io credo che non mi alzerò
mai più magari non ci verrà subito però
comunque io e te siamo dei
professionisti
a un certo punto verrà dai promo una
cosa assurda
allora jessica dice vestirsi da clown e
attendere la gente in fondo ad una
strada i potenti avevo promesso aver
fatto qualcosa faccio io è mai
immaginati a me al buio vestito da clown
pauroso io secondo me faccio paura non
ha paura nessuno di me come si chiama
poi serena dice una cosa che mi
piacerebbe fare sarebbe fare un regalo
ad uno sconosciuto che bene sarà questa
bellissima
ciao siamo ragazzi del piano di sopra
che visto che si sta un po avvicinando
al natale allora stavamo pensando di
portare dei regali così posso proporre
solo una cosa solamente perché lo
scaramantico è assurdo la band alla tua
sotto prima l ha trovata grazie sandro
scrive mangiare un'arancia sotto la
doccia perché io non posso fare la
doccia con un uomo ma sono tanti anni
che non provi un brivido ed è giusto che
arrivi per te grazie sandro sfoderò la
mia cuffia da doccia i vecchi il primo
oggetto friendly e mi viene è un pò
cantina questa cosa non mi dire tutti i
prodotti che gira nel frattempo ne
approfitti dopo lo capisce a quale è
allora però di andare sotto
non è male che devi soffiare in fuori e
poi era già bellissimo
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video speriamo veramente che vi
sia piaciuto
fatecelo sapere nei commenti noi vi
dedichiamo un brindisi e vi auguriamo di
avere sempre voglia di novità questa
volta la sfida della proponiamo noi
esatto che se oggi domani o quando vi
pare fate qualcosa di nuovo
sì se qualunque cosa vi venga in mente
purché sia nuovo però fatelo per voi
cin cin